I Nina how are you I'm doing good
damn how are you better than I deserve
what's up I would call in to just kind
of get some advice from you
I'm currently 28 I'll be 29 in a couple
weeks and I have a five-year-old son
that it has a disability so the past
almost like year and a half I haven't
been working just kind of taking care of
him so I used to make between 60 to 65
thousand dollars a year it went down to
making absolutely nothing and I made
some really poor decisions and I'm
really deep in debt right now so my
question is is that this front is coming
Friday I'm actually going to be starting
any job where I'm going to be making
approximately $35,000 a year but I just
don't know where to start and what I I'm
scared of is I'm here does like walking
in there and all of a sudden getting the
check and going back to living like I
was making a lot more money than when
I'm baking right now and I just kind of
wanted your advice on that hmm so you're
single yeah then you have a baby that's
hold keep fries okay all right and if
you used to make 60 why are you taking a
job now that makes only 35 well I'm
originally from New Jersey so the pay
rate is way different in New Jersey
versus Florida but when I was making
fifty to sixty five thousand dollars a
year I was paying a whole lot of money
in rent I was paying a whole lot of
money what were you doing what were you
doing I used to work himself okay there
are sales jobs in Florida that do not
that are not half of New Jersey the pay
rate of Orlando is not half of New
Jersey on anything so that's just not
that's not accurate so sales anybody who
knows how to sell can make money and so
is the new job got upside where you're
selling no the new job is strictly
customer service but there is potential
for me to move into another department
where I will be doing so
making a commission but it's just I got
hired I went to a hiring event and I
kind of just took like the first thing
that they had available that's what I
thought
and so you settled okay I just want you
to make more money because I think
you've proven that you can make 60
thousand and we're not blaming that on
Jersey versus Florida I'm blaming that
on your job selection so let's move back
towards sales because if you know how to
sell kiddo you can always make some good
money selling is one of the best paid
professions out there you got a lot of
opportunity there so to answer your
question the way you control the
paycheck whether it's thirty five or the
sixty five I want you to go make either
one you tell the money what to do on
paper before the month begins and once
you've told the money what to do on
paper then that paper is the boss of you
it's called your budget you're the boss
of it until you get it down remember
when your little kid and you said you're
not the boss of me yeah well that's the
deal here you're the boss of that piece
of paper until you get it written out
and once you get it written out then
it's the boss of you it's your map on
how to go to Disneyland it's your map on
how to go to winning land where you get
to win with money and if you do
something with money other than what you
planned to do then you're being a child
again and you're not a child anymore now
you're an adult you're raising a child
you can do this right you absolutely can
do this I can tell you can do this by
the way the tone of your voice is you're
ready to do this right for the first
time in your life I'm gonna help you I
want you to hold on I'm gonna give you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover I'm gonna show you every step
of what you need to do and jump online
and download the app for your phone
called every dollar it's a free
budgeting app and it'll help you put
your budget together and then you tell
this money what to do you make this
money behave that's what's necessary